I WANT TO GO AHEAD AND START THE
ASSEMBLY A GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND I
CALL IT THE ORDER I'M GONNA
BEGIN BY HANDING IT OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR OF THIS ANY COMMENTS
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE. FIRST THINGS
FIRST I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE TO THE HEARING.
REALLY APPRECIATE E. R.
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS THAT AND
ATTENTION FROM ALL PARTIES IN
THIS COME FOR THE- LOOK FORWARD
TO THE- TESTIMONY THIS GOING TO
BE GIVEN BY ALL. THE DAY- AND-
GRAB YOU AT THAT AND- ANYWAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I THINK
IF I SECURE I. S. THE COULD
PUBLIC MEMBERS- IT'S TRADITION
FOR ME TO LOT ANYBODY MAKES
OPENING COMMENTS ALONG THE- A-
YEAH MAIS GET- I REPRESENT-
COMMITTEE AND- NEW HERE SUFFER
FROM FOLKS MAY KNOW OF MILLER-
ONE PICKED UP TO WELCOME
EVERYONE TODAY THE DATA TO
INFORMATIONAL. I'M SEE A COUPLE
HEALTH- COUPLE HOUSEKEEPING
THING WITH CITY ARE CALLING FOR
PUBLIC COM IS. 877-692-8957 ARE
REPEAT THAT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE. EIGHT NINE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ONE ZERO ZERO. ONE
EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO
THIS CAN ALSO BE FOUND IN THE
COMMITTEES WERE AND IT'S ON YOUR
SCREEN. THE CALLING IN PLEASE
ARE TO MEET. ALL IN THE QUEUE
AND TO ELIMINATE ANY BACKGROUND
NOISE. YOU ALSO BE PLACE IN THE
QUEUE UNTIL YOUR OFFER. TO
PROVIDE COMMENT. WHAT IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITIES YOUR OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT PRIEST
PLUS ONE. ZERO AND A MEET
YOURSELF IN ORDER SPEAKER REPEAT
THAT ONE MORE TIME PRIEST. PRESS
ONE ZERO AND I MEET YOURSELF IN
ORDER TO SPEAK. UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS I WILL BE ASKING YOU TO
BE BRIEF IN YOUR COMMENTS YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY. FIVE THE TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACT BEFORE US TODAY
WERE EXECUTED ARE MARCH TWENTY.
TWENTY TWO BETWEEN THE GOOD-
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE
FOLLOWING TO. MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA A POMO INDIANS
CALIFORNIA. N. AS SANTA ROSA
INDIAN COMMUNITY OF THE SANTA
ROSA ANDREA. TODAY WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS OF
THE COMPACTS- THAT IS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AND THE CHAIR
OF EACH TRIBE. LAST OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE RATIFIED.
AB NINE FIVE SEVEN BY SUMMER
SALAS- THE GRANTED THESE TWO
SAME TRIBES A NEW COMPACT TO
REPLACE THE CURRENT NINETEEN
NINETY NINE COMBAT. AFTER THE
LATEST ROUND OF EACH IN.
REPLICATION THE CONTACTS WERE
SUBMITTED TO THE SICK SECRETARY
OF THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT
OF INTERIOR- WHERE THEY WERE
REQUIRED A FORTY FIVE DAY REVIEW
. IN NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ASSISTANT SECRETARY
DISAPPROVE THE TWO CONTACTS. IN
THE CONTACTS CONTAINS SEVERAL
PROVISIONS THAT EXCEED THE
LIMITATION ON COMBAT
NEGOTIATIONS. IN ESSENCE THE
COMPAQ CONTAIN TERMS THAT WERE
OUTSIDE THE NARROW SCOPE OF THE
IN THE GAME IN REGULATION ACT.
REGULATORY ACT THESE NEWLY
NEGOTIATED COMPACTS ARE NOW
EXECUTED ON MARCH TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
ARTICULATION OF LENGTHY MEG
NEGOTIATION PROCESS COMPROMISES
AND CAREFUL CONSIDERATION OF
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT THE UNITED
STATES NON SIR NINTH CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS PRESIDENT AND A
TECHNICAL GUIDANCE FIRE A
COMPACT APPROVALS AND FEDERAL
PROCEDURES ISSUED BY UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR.
EACH COMPACT AUTHORIZES THE
TRIED TO OPERATE A MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF GAMING DEVICES AS A
DESIGNATED NUMBER A GAMING
FACILITIES LOCATED ELLAGIC. ON
ELIGIBLE INDIAN LANDS HELD IN
TRUSTFOR THE TRIBES AND LOCATED
WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF THE
TRIBE'S RESERVATION. UNDER EACH
COMPACT THE TRIBES AGREED TO PAY
THE STATE- IT'S PRO RATA SHARE
OF COST THAT THE STAVING CURSE
FOR THE PERFORMANCE OF ITS
DUTIES UNDER THE COMPACT. THE
COMPACT INCLUDES PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOW. OFF RESERVATION
MITIGATION AND ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS IF YOU DISPUTE WERE TO
ARISE. I AM PLEASED TO SEE THESE
COMPACT. THAT THE COMPACT MIRROR
MANY OF THE RECENT CONTACTS THAT
HAVE COME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE AREA OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS. MEANINGFUL CONSUMER
AND EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS AND
LABOR PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW
WORKERS TO UNIONIZE UNDER.
SPECIFIED CONDITIONS. ONCE
AFFECTED THESE COMPACT WILL BE
IN FULL FORCE AND EFFECT THE FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO FOLLOW THE-
EFFECTIVE DATE. I JUST WANNA
REMIND ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
WILL BE NO FORMAL VOTE- TAKEN
TODAY AND REMIND THE AUDIENCE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY'S
HEARING. ON THE COMMITTEE IS
ONLY BE BRIEFED ON THE CONTENTS
OF IT'S COMPACT AND THEY CANNOT
BE AMENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SB NINE HUNDRED BY CENTER HURDLE
IS AROUND. OF FOR THE MIDDLETON
RANCHERIA POMO INDIANS- AND FOR
THE SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
CENTER ALSO RANCHERIA. CONTACTS
AT SOME POINT SB NINE HUNDRED BE
TAKEN UP FOR CONSIDERATION BY
ENTIRE BODY OF THE LETTER OF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I LIKE TO THINK
OUR WITNESSES IN ADVANCE FOR
TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULES TO BE WITH US HERE
TODAY I WITHOUT FOOD YOU'LL WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND BEGIN IN THE
FIRST CONTACT OTHER WILL BE
BRIEFED ON TODAY WILL BE THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA POMO
INDIANS OF CALIFORNIA- AND OUR
FIRST SPEAKER TODAY WILL BE. A
TIMBER GOALIE OF THE SENIOR
ADVISER FOR THE TRIBAL
NEGOTIATED FOR THE TRIBAL
NEGOTIATIONS OF ISER FOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM I. CONTACT US.
BELIEVE YOU SO HE MAY BEGIN. AND
THANK YOU. YES YOU MAY YOU MAY
PLEASE- YET CHECKER SIMON PLEASE
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WITH US TODAY.
AND I WANNA MAKE ONE QUICK
COMMENT TO WE'VE JUST LEARNED
THAT- THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM H.
E. R. E- WILL NOT BE HERE TODAY.
BUT WE MAY PROCEED. WITH OTHER
REPRESENTATIVE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR SANTIAGO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANKS FOR THE
TIME TAG OVER THESE CONTACTS
TODAY MY NAME IS NATHAN VOCALLY
AND I'M THAT GOVERNOR'S SENIOR
ADVISER FOR TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS
. THIS IS THE SECOND TIME IN THE
PAST YEAR THAT I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO OVER THE
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACTS.
GAMING COMPACT FOR THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA. BEFORE I
BEGIN I'D LIKE TO THANK
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA CHAIR AS A
SIMON FOR HIS TRIBE'S HARD WORK
TO REACH AGREEMENT ON THIS
CONTACT. I'LL BEGIN TODAY WITH A
BRIEF BACKGROUND ON THE TRIBAL
STATE COMPACT IN PROCESS. AND
THE REASON JUST APPROVALS BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR THAT YOU
HAD MENTIONED. ALL OF THEM
TURNED TO THE TERMS OF THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA COMPACT
SOME OF WHICH YOU'VE ALREADY
TOUCHED ON. OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN
PROPOSITION ONE A. APPROVED
AMENDING THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. TO ALLOW TRIBES TO
OPERATE SLOT MACHINES BANKING IN
PERCENTAGE CARD GAMES AND
LOTTERY GAMES ON INDIAN LANDS.
UNDER THE FEDERAL INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT OR A GROUND A
TRIBE CAN OFFER THE SLOT
MACHINES IN CLASS THREE GAMES IF
THE TRIBE HAS NEGOTIATED A
TRIBAL STATE CLASS THREE GAMING
COMPACT. THEY WERE BROADLY
LIMITS COMPACTS TO SUBJECTS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
OPERATION OF GAMING ACTIVITIES.
PURSUANT TO PROP ONE EIGHTY AND
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THE
GOVERNOR NEGOTIATES IN A TRIBE A
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT WITH
THE TRIBE AND THEN PRESENT IT TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR RATIFICATION
. ONCE RATIFIED IT REQUIRES THE
COMPACT TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE
SECRETARY OF THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR FOR A
FORTY FIVE DAY REVIEW. DURING
THAT FORTY FIVE REVIEW THE
SECRETARY CAN APPROVE THE
COMPACT DISAPPROVE THE CONTACT
OR NOT ACT ON IT IN WHICH CASE
THE CONTACT IS DEEMED APPROVED.
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA IS
CURRENTLY OPERATING UNDER A
COMPACT SIGNED IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. SET TO EXPIRE IN
JUNE OF THIS YEAR. IN APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA SIGNED A NEW TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACT. I WAS
RATIFIED BY THE LATE LEGISLATURE
LAST AUGUST. MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIAS CONTACT ALONG WITH
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIAS COMPACT
THAT WE'LL HEAR ABOUT LATER. WAS
ONE OF THREE CONTACTS
DISAPPROVED IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR. INTERIOR ISSUED A
LETTER AT THE TIME THAT IT
EXPLAINED IN ITS VIEW WHY THE
COMPACT EXCEEDED THE SCOPE OF
TOPICS AUTHORIZED BIOGRAPHY. AS
A RESULT OF THE SECRETARY'S
DISAPPROVAL THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE CONDUCTED A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF PRIOR CALIFORNIA
COMPACTS. NINTH CIRCUIT CASE LAW
AND CONTACTS AND OTHER STATES.
INFORMED BY THIS WORK THE STATE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA UPDATED ITS
TWENTY COMPACT. MAJORITY OF THE
TERMS IN MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIAS
UPDATED CONTACT REMAIN THE SAME
AS THAT PREVIOUSLY RATIFIED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN AUGUST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT REFLECTS EXISTING
TRAVEL POLICIES AND THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT NATURE
OF THE TRIBAL STATE
RELATIONSHIPS. THE COMPACT
IRMA'S FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
INCLUDES FORCE MEASURE LANGUAGE
TO ADDRESS REDUCED OPERATIONS OR
CLOSURES FROM PANDEMICS. WILD
FIRES AND OTHER EVENTS OUTSIDE
OF THE TRIBES CONTROL. IT ALSO
GRANTS THE TRIBE. THE RIGHT TO
TERMINATE OR NEGOTIATE AN
AMENDMENT IF THAT IF TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA LOSE THEIR EXCLUSIVE
RIGHT TO OPERATE GAMING DEVICES
. THE GAMING FACILITY DEFINITION
IN THIS UPDATED CONTACT WAS
REVISED TO MORE CLOSELY TRACKED
DEFINITIONS PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
BY THE SECRETARY OF INTERIOR.
THE SCOPE OF THE DEFINITION WAS
NARROWED CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
RECENT CONTACTS THE FOCUS ON
FACILITIES WITH THE PRINCIPAL
PURPOSE OF SERVING THE GAMING
OPERATION. MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA
COMMITTED TO OUR PRO RATA SHARE
OF PAYMENTS TO THE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND OR STF AS IT'S
CALLED. WHICH IS USED TO
REIMBURSE THE STATE ITS REGULAR
AND OTHER DIRECT COSTS A TRIBAL
GAMING. IN RECOGNITION OF PRIOR
PREPAYMENT OF FEES FOR UNUSED
GAME LICENSES MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIAS CONTACT ALSO PROVIDES
FOR A CREDIT AGAINST ITS STAFF
STF OBLIGATION. THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA THROUGH ITS TWIN PINE
CASINO IN LAKE COUNTY CURRENTLY
OPERATES UNDER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY GAMING DEVICES. IF IT
CONTINUES TO OPERATE LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY. AS A
LIMITED GAMING TRIBE IT'LL-REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR ONE POINT
ONE MILLION ANNUALLY FROM THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND R. R.
S. T. F. R. S. T. F. AS THE
PRIMARY SOURCE OF REVENUE. FOR
THAT ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DISBURSEMENT TEACH LIMITED AND
NON GAMING TRIBES. IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDS MAY BE MADE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE TRAVEL NAY FUND. THE
TRIBE COULD EXPAND ITS
OPERATIONS TO UP TO ONE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES
ACROSS TO FACILITIES. WITH NO
ADDITIONAL ARE STF PAYMENT
OBLIGATIONS. THE COMPACT INCLUDE
STANDARDS FOR GAMING REGULATION
LICENSING AND GAMING DEVICE
TESTING AND INSPECTIONS. IT ALSO
ADDRESSES HEALTH SAFETY AND
LABOR PROTECTIONS FOR EMPLOYEES
AND VISITORS. IN THIS APPROVING
THE PRIOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CONTACTS THE SECRETARY OF
INTERIOR EXPRESSED CONCERNS THAT
THE COMPACTS BROADLY REGULATED
TOBACCO SALES. CONSISTENT WITH
THE INTENT OF THE STATE AND THE
TRIBES. TWENTY ONE CONTACTS THIS
UPDATED CONTACT THOSE THAT
FOCUSES ON PROHIBITING TOBACCO
SALES TO MINORS AT THE GAMING
FACILITY IN ACCORDANCE WITH
FEDERAL LAW. WHICH REQUIRES A
PURCHASER TO BE TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD JUST AS FOR STATE LAW.
ADDITIONALLY THE TRIBES AGREED
TO CONTINUE ITS PRACTICE OF
RECOGNIZING STATE SPOUSAL AND
CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS. AGAINST
NON TRIBAL MEMBER CASINO
EMPLOYEES BUT THE UPDATED
PROVISION HIGHLIGHTSTHE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS AS A
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS. THE
CONTACTING CORPORATIONS
TRAVELODGE RESTING PATRON
DISPUTES TORTS AND EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS. THE TRIBE
COMMITS TO ENSURING MINIMUM WAGE
RATES AT LEAST AS STRINGENT AS
CALIFORNIA'S AND TO MAINTAINING
A TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE. IT ALSO AGREED TO
REVISE LANGUAGE REGARDING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE TO CLARIFY
THE INTENT OF THE TRIBE IN THE
STATE. THAT BY AGREEING T
MAINTAIN THE ORDINANCE THE TRIBE
IS ALSO AGREEING TO COMPLY WITH
IT. THE TLR OVER TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE TAKES EFFECT
WHEN A TRIBE EMPLOYS TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY OR MORE PEOPLE AT ITS
GAMING RELATED FACILITIES. NOT
COUNTING TRIBAL MEMBERS. THE
TLR- FUNCTIONS AS THE MECHANISM
FOR A BILATERAL CONTRACT BETWEEN
THE TRIBE AND THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION. WITH CORRESPONDING
COMMITMENTS AND OBLIGATIONS BY
EACH. LITTLE TOWN RANCHERIAS
COMPACT ALSO INCORPORATES ROBUST
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OF GAMING
PROJECTS BY IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
OPPOSITION IMPACTS AN
APPROPRIATE MITIGATION. THE
UPDATED CONTACT LIMITS THE SCOPE
OF COVERED PROJECTS TO
DEVELOPMENT TYPE ACTIVITIES
CONSISTENT WITH THE LIGHT STATES
LONG STANDING APPROACH TO
CONTACT IMPLEMENTATION. THE
COMPACT PARALLEL STATE AND
FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESSES ALLOWING FOR
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS AND
NEGATIVE DECLARATIONS. THAT
DATACOM ALSO CLARIFIED WHO IN
WHEN THE TRIBE MUST NOTIFY.
DURING THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS WHICH ENTITIES ARE ABLE
TO REQUEST A MEETING CONFER WITH
THE TRIBE REGARDING MITIGATION.
IF THE TRIBE IS NOT ABLE TO
SUFFICIENTLY MITIGATE OR AVOID
IMPACTS THAN THE TRIBE MAY
COMPLETE A STREAMLINED TRIBAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT DOCUMENT.
IT WILL BE OPERATING LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY GAMING
DEVICES OR OTHERWISE IT WOULD
NEED TO DO A FULL TRIBAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT. THE
TRIBE MUST ALSO COMMIT TO
MITIGATION FOR IMPACTS ON THE
LOCAL CITY COUNTY OR CALTRANS IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES. IF AN
AGREEMENT IS NOT REACHED ON
MITIGATION. EITHER THE TRIBE OR
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT MAY SEEK
ARBITRATION TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE
. FINALLY THE COMPACT INCLUDES A
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS TO
ADDRESS ANY ALLEGED BREACH IN TO
ENFORCE CONTACT TERMS. CONTACT
IS TO ENCOURAGE GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS TO RESOLVE
DISAGREEMENTS. BUT ULTIMATELY
PROVIDES FOR COURT RESOLUTION IF
NECESSARY. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES TIME TO GO OVER
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIAS UPDATED
CONTACT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE BELIEVES DRESSES THAT
APARTMENT INTERIORS CONCERNS.
ARE REMAIN AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS CAN BE MADE OUT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
VERY MUCH- MISTOOK IT WITH THE
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO GO
CHAIRMAN SIMON AND MAYBE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS AT THAT
POINT TIME WE GO BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- CHAIRMAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. IF YOU WISH YOU
YOU MAY. YOU'RE ALSO WELCOME TO
CONTINUE SITTING IF YOU'D LIKE
THAT'S OKAY ALL STAND UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR TODAY.
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MYSELF AS A
MOXON THE THIRD MANY HE CLOCKED
UP OAK SIMON THE TRIBAL CHAIRMAN
OF THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA
REPRESENT THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA POMERANIANS WHICH IS A
COMBINATION OF PALMER WINTUN AND
LET ME WALK ON THE SOUTHERN SIDE
OF LAKE COUNTY. WE OWN AND
OPERATE THE TWIN PINE CASINO
THAT HAS BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
TWENTY TWO YEARS NOW I THINK
WE'RE GOING ON RIGHT NOW I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE THE TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN WHEN WE NEGOTIATED THE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE COMPACT
ACROSS WE'VE GOT A GREAT. BECOME
A GREAT DAY TODAY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE APPROVAL OF
THIS NEW COMPACT FOR THE NEXT
TWENTY FIVE OF PEOPLE. WE'VE
BEEN IN AREA FOR TWELVE THE
YEARS AND LAY COUNTY. WILL
CONTINUE BE THAT WAY AS WE FOR.
WE CURRENTLY. WITH ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES LOCALLY
EMPLOYED HERE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ONE OF THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS AND
SOFTLY COUNTY. ROVER THE LAST
SIX YEARS WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
MANY DISASTERS TIMES. SO YOUR
CALL IS ONE OF REPRESENTATIVES
ALONG WITH YOU FOR ALL THE HELP
WITH. THE STATE IS PROUD TO OUR
COUNTY AND OUR OUR- PEOPLE AND
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED. AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS AS WE
SAID THIS IS THE SECOND TIME WE
MOVED THROUGH I WANT TO THANK
THE STATE FOR THEIR COOPERATION.
THIS IS A GOOD AGREEMENT FOR
BOTH THE STATE AND THE TRIBES.
WANT NEW THAT OPERATION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. EACH DAY THAT WE
GO THROUGH. WITH UNCERTAINTY IS
HARD FOR MY PEOPLE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THIS WILL ALLOW US TO
HAVE A GOOD SOLID BASE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. WITH NEGOTIATIONS
EXPANSIONS AND OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SIDE. OF OUR TRIBE.
THE GOVERNMENT GAMING OPERATIONS
PROVIDES HOUSING. EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. MENTAL HEALTH.
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
ROADS EVERYTHING YOU'D YOU'D SEE
IN A SMALL GOVERNMENT THIS WITH
THIS OPERATION DOES FORCE. WE
ARE VERY TIED TO OUR COMMUNITY.
I NOT ONLY SERVICE TROUBLE
CHAIRMAN AND I'M ALSO THE FIRST
NATIVE AMERICAN ELECTED. TO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN LAKE
COUNTY. THROUGHOUT THE DISASTER
TIMES. YOU DO NOTHING BUT TRY TO
GIVE BACK TO OUR COMMUNITIES TO
HELP REBUILD. WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT THIS OPPORTUNITY IS
BEING GIVEN TO US BY THE STATE.
I TELL YOU HOW PROUD I AM. OF
THE WORK THAT WAS DONE BY BOTH
OUR ATTORNEYS. THE TO BOWL THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. SO TODAY
ASKED BEFORE YOU. HOLD OFF THE
TOP. IN ORDER THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HERE TESTIFY
TODAY. WILL BE A VERY FOR
QUESTIONS SO. ABOUT THE COTABATO
PEOPLE OF THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA GREATLY APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HE WAS THE CHAIRMAN. IF
THERE'S ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ABOUT YES THAT'S CORRECT. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW IS THAT
WHEN YOU'VE GONE THROUGH SO MANY
DISASTERS WE'VE IN LAKE COUNTY.
IS THE CHAIRMAN HAS NEVER LOOKED
LOOKED DOWN AND IT IS
CONSTITUENCIES TAKE CARE OF
EVERY SINGLE CONSTITUENT IN THE
AREA. AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW
TO BEGIN TO THINK YOU CAN OFFER
YOUR SERVICE ALSO A LOT OF
PEOPLE DIDN'T REALIZE HE'S A
SUPERVISOR IN LAKE COUNTY NEWS
DOING AN INCREDIBLE JOB
REPRESENTING. HIS CONSTITUENTS
AND SO AGAIN I THANK YOU. THIS
IS GREAT NEWS FOR ALL OF US AND
NOT AFFORD TO MANY MORE YEARS OF
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE IS ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. I'M NOT SEEING ANY SO
I'M GONNA GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
IF THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. HERE WHO ARE TO HEAR
COMMENTS WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT
IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION.
ADDITIONALLY. LIKEWISE I WOULD
GO TO THE PHONES AND ASK THE
MODERATORS AS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON
THE PHONES PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. SURE WE HAVE
NO RESPONSE ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU TO SEE A- THE MORE
PEOPLE CAME HIS ONE MORE TIME
FOR A PUBLIC FOR COMMENT FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF NOT I'M
GONNA THANK YU VERY MUCH. FOR
COMING DOWN HERE TODAY-
PRESENTING- BOTH OF YOU AND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THIS. YOUR
ANY COMMENT SO. THE NEXT PART
LIKE I SAID IN THE OPENING
COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON THIS
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP THAT'S A BEEN
STRICKEN HERE AND OUR STRUCTURE
AND SO THAT. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THIS AS IT MOVES
FORWARD THROUGH THE PROCESS WHEN
IT COMES BEFORE US. AND
CONGRATULATE YOU AND
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR-
EFFORTS AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
THAT'S- WHERE I STARTED IN
POLITICS IN IT'S A GREAT FEELING
RIGHT THERE AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SO. YOU GOT TWO SHOTS
AT IT I REALLY. REMOVE ON. FOR
OKAY I APOLOGIZE DEAR TO THE
HEARTS OF THE TRIBES THAT
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP IS SO IMPORTANT- I
WANT CHECKING OUR SOVEREIGNTY
AND YOU GUYS ARE DOING THE SAME
FOR THE PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THAT COLLABORATION AS WE WORK
TOGETHER TO MOVE ALL
CALIFORNIA'S FORTS OF THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. YOUR SPENT WITH US
AND YOUR PRESENTATION. AS WELL
AS MOST OF THE GOALIE AND THE
AND THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF WHO.
WHO- WORKED ON THIS TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN SO THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH. AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON THE
NEXT PAGE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. VERY HONORED.
AND IF YOU DECIDE LIKE THE CALL-
GERMAN CISCO UP AND- I'LL TAKE A
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE. AT
THE CONGRATULATED HIM FOR HIS
BIRTHDAY I BELIEVE IT WAS
YESTERDAY. SO WE'LL DO IT THE
OLD FASHIONED WAY. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO THE- I WILL SUBJECT
YOU TO THAT CHAIRMAN BUT KNOW
THAT IT'S IN MY HEART THAT WISH
YOU HAPPY BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH- WE WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN- BEGIN THIS.
FOR BOGEY IF YOU LIKE A PRESENT
. THANK YOU. THANKS AGAIN SERVER
THIS ONE AND I'LL SAY IT JUST TO
START OFF THE SANTA ROSA COMPACT
REFLECTS THAT RESPECTFUL
RELATIONSHIP WE TALKED ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
EIGHT IT INCLUDES A SIMILAR
TERMS TO THOSE THAT I DESCRIBED
IN THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA
COMPACT THE RATHER THAN GO
THROUGH ALL OF THEM AGAIN I'LL
HIGHLIGHT A FEW KEY POINTS I
WANT TO THANK SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA CHAIR LEO CISCO FOR
JOINING US TODAY. SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA LIKE MIDDLE RANCHERIAS
CONDUCTING GAMING PURSUANT TO A
NINETEEN NINETY NINE COMPACT
THAT EXPIRES IN JUNE OF THIS
YEAR. THE LEGISLATURE IN AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE RATIFIED ITS
NEW COMPACT. BUT THAT CONTACT
WAS ALSO DISAPPROVED IN NOVEMBER
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WORKED IN
CLOSE CORRECT COLOR COORDINATION
WITH THE SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA TO
UPDATE ITS TWENTY TWENTY ONE
COMPACT TO ADDRESS THE PRIMARY
CONCERN EXPRESSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR.
CONSISTENT WITH NINTH CIRCUIT
CASE LAW IN OUR REVIEW OF PAST
INTERIOR ACTIONS. THIS UPDATED
CONTACT WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE GREAT
EFFORTS OF TE SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA TO NEGOTIATE A COMPACT
THAT PROTECTS BOTH PARTIES
INTERESTS AND ADDRESSES
INTERIORS CONCERNS. SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA CURRENTLY OPERATES
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
GAMING DEVICES AT ITS TACHI
PALACE CASINO RESORT IN KINGS
COUNTY. UNDER THE NEW CONTACTS
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA WILL BE
ABLE TO OPERATE UP TO THREE
THOUSAND TOTAL GAMING DEVICES
ACROSS THREE FACILITIES. IT
COMMITTED TO PAYING ITS PRO RATA
SHARE OF STATE REGULATORY COSTS
TO THE SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION
FUND. WHEN THE TRIBE IS
OPERATING OVER TWO HUNDRED
GAMING DEVICES IT WILL
CONTRIBUTE FOUR AND A QUARTER
PERCENT OF ITS GROSS GAMING
REVENUE OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THIS IS TO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUNDER ARE STF.
RESURRECT THREE IS ABLE TO
CREDIT AGAINST ITS ARE STF
OBLIGATION IT'S PAYMENTS TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FOR FIRE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT SERVICES. AND
FOR ITS PAYMENTS SUPPORTING LOOK
HOUSING ELDERS AND OTHERS IN
FINANCIAL NEED. TO ADDRESS THE
APARTMENT INTERIORS CONCERNS THE
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA COMPACT
INCLUDES THE REVISED DEFINITION
OF GAMING FACILITY THAT I
DESCRIBED FOR MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA. IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT ONLY GAMING DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES TRIGGER AT THE
REQUIRED ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
BECAUSE SANTA ROSA RANCHERIAS
ALREADY OPERATING WELL OVER
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY GAMING
DEVICES THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS REQUIRES FULL TRIBAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT FOR
A GAMING PROJECT THAT WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTION OR NEGATIVE
DECLARATION. AS FOR MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS IN SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIAS UPDATED CONTACT
CLARIFY WHO IN WHICH ENTITIES
ARE NOTIFIED OF A NEW PROJECT.
THE BACK OF SALES TO MINORS ARE
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBITED IN THIS
COMPACT THE TRIBAL CONTINUE TO
RECOGNIZE STATE CHILD AND
SPOUSAL SUPPORT ORDERS AGAINST
NON TRIBAL MEMBER CASINO
EMPLOYEES. SANTA ROSA RANCHERIAS
UPDATED CONTACT INCLUDES THE
SAME TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE FROM ITS TWENTY TWENTY
ONE COMPACT. THE TRIBE ALSO
AGREED TO LANGUAGE CLARIYING
THE PARTIES INTENT THAT
MAINTAINING THAT TRIBAL REALLY
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE
INCLUDES COMPLIANCE WITH IT.
THIS UPDATED SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA CONTACT IS THE
CULMINATION OF MONTHS OF STATE
AND TRIBAL EFFORTS. TO
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SUPPORTS ITS
RATIFICATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND ALL THAT ALL REMAIN
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONCE AGAIN.
AND TERM CISCO IF YOU IF YOU'D
BE SO KIND OF THE PRESENT IN THE
SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY OF
THE SANTA ROSA RENTERIA. IMPAX.
THANK YOU THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. HI MY NAME IS LEO
CISCO AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE WAS A RANCHERIA TOUCHY
OKAY TRIBE. I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE HUNDRED.
WHICH RATIFIED THE AMENDMENT OF
THE RANCHERIA TRIBE CAME COMPACT
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK CENTER
TADO. FOR AUTHORING SB NINE
HUNDRED. AND CO AUTHORS
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS EDUARDO GARCIA.
DEVON MATHIS. AND JAMES ALMOST.
FOR THE CONTINUED SUPPORT OF OUR
CONTACT THANK YOU. I THINK THE
MANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS
REMOVE THIS CONTACT FOR TO
RATIFICATION. SENATE WAS
RENTERIA IS LOCATED AT THE HEART
OF THE SILICON VALLEY IN THE
MARKET JUST SOUTH OF THE MORE
CALIFORNIA. IN KINGS COUNTY. FOR
THE NINETEEN NINETY NINE TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACT. OUR TRIBE
CURRENTLY OPERATES ATTACH
APOSTASY RESORT WITH TWO
THOUSAND GAMING DEVICES AND
EMPLOYS OVER ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. THE TRIBE HAS
FOSTERED A GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH A DETERMINATION
TO INCREASE THE STANDARD OF
LIVING. AND QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
ITS MEMBERS AND THE KINGS COUNTY
COMMUNITY. THE TRIBE HAS
ESTABLISHED SEVERAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ENTERPRISES. SUCH A
PALACE CASINO RESORTS. SEQUOIA
IN WHICH IS THE CITY OF HANFORD.
OKAY GAS. CARD ENTERTAINMENT
CENTER AND TAX REFORMS.
PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND CATERING TO
THE ENTERTAINMENT LODGING THESE
OF THE TRIBE. AND THE KINGS
COUNTY COMMUNITY. FURTHERMORE
THE TRIBE DEDICATION TO IMPROVE
THE WELFARE OF TRIBAL MEMBERS
AND THE KINGS COUNTY COMMUNITY.
AS EVIDENCED IN THE CONTINUED
EXPANSION OF TROUBLE GOVERNMENT
DEPARTMENTS. THANK REGIONAL
TRAVEL PROGRAMS BY FUNDING 1100%
OF HIGHER EDUCATION FOR OUR
TRIBAL MEMBERS. POSSESSING A
PROACTIVE SOCIAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT TO ASSIST OUR
MEMBERS. JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS
COMMUNITY MAINTENANCE. IN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL AND FUNDS
CLEAN DRINKING WATER PROJECTS
FOR LOCAL SCHOOLS. THE CENTER
WAS ORIGINALLY A TOUCH OF THE
TRIBE BANKING'S COUNTY SIGNED
INTER GOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENT TO
ALLOW THE CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW
FIRE STATION ON TRIBAL LANDS
INSURING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT FOR
THE COUNTY. AS WELL AS THE TAXI
PALACE YOUR- THE NEW COMPACT'S
ENHANCES. IT'S A FAIR AND HONEST
OPERATION IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE INTERESTS OF THE TRIBE THE
STATE ITS CITIZENS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. UNDER THE NEW
COMPACT THE TRIBE IS AUTHORIZED
OPERATE UP TO THREE THOUSAND
GAMING DEVICES ON ELIGIBLE
LANDS. HELD IN TRUST FOR THE
TRIBE. THE LICENSING REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION PATRON
PROTECTION LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY SERVICES ALSO ARE
SIMILAR TO OTHER RECENT
CONTACTS. WITH MANY REVISIONS
WHICH ARE MORE FAVORABLE TO THE
TRIBE. ADULT YOGA ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF FOR CALIFORNIA
IN RENEWING ITS COMMITMENT TO
OUR PEOPLE. WE ARE PLEASED THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS TROUBLE
NEGOTIATOR NATHAN VOCALLY ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS FRAMEWORK.
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL
AND RATIFYING AHRP COMPACT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. OUR COMPACT
SUPPORTER BY THE KINGS COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. KINGS
COUNTY SHERIFF DAVID ROBINSON.
KINGS COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
THE CITY OF LAMAR. CALIFORNIA
NATIONS INDIAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION. AS WELL AS OUR AREA
CONGRESSMAN DAVE ALL DALE. WE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
DINER AND I WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS AS WELL. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW YOU HAVE ON
YOUR AGENDA STATED. FOR SOME
NEEDED HERE AT THE BEGINNING. OF
THOSE ARE REPRESENTED FROM HRT.
THAT PERSONAL WASN'T ISN'T HERE
TODAY. SO THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND SKIP. I THAT
PORTION OF THE PRESENTATIONS AND
JUST GO DIRECTLY TO ANY
COMMENTS. OR QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MIGHT HAVE.
YES WITH MATHIS.
THANK YOU IN THE TOUCHY OKAY
PEOPLE FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO IN
THE COMMUNITY IT REALLY MEANS A
LOT TO SEE. THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
TO DEVELOP AND GROW INTO
CONTINUE. YOU KNOW THE THINGS
FOR THE SCHOOL FOR THE WATER FOR
ALL OF IT IN THE COMMUNITY TO
THE SEIZE IT AND I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU. I THINK THE TRIBE FOR
THE ONGOING EFFORTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER ROGERS. MISTER MISTER
RAMOS AND THE METS QUIRK-SILVA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU TO
VULTURES UP FOR PRESENTING THAT
THE COMPACTS BEFORE US TODAY
INTO THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
WORKING OUT SOME OF THESE-
TECHNICAL AREAS ON FOR THESE
COMPACTS TO MOVE FORWARD
CERTAINLY IT MOVES AND EMPOWERS
ON THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN
YOUR AREAS THAT YOU REPRESENT.
FROM EDUCATION TO THE DIFFERENT
JOBS THAT ARE BEING CREATED SO
WE LOOK- WHOLEHEARTEDLY TO
SUPPORT THESE BILLS- AS THEY
MOVE FORWARD TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR I DON'T THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE TRAVELER
CARE SOME COMING TOGETHER TO
WORK THROUGH SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES. THANK YOU. I YES SAME
CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUES- AS
FAR AS THE- EXTENSIVE EFFORT BUT
I DID HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
MINISTRATION- YOU MENTION REALLY
QUICKLY THAT YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO COLLECT. I THOUGHT YOU SAID
OF SOME TYPE OF- FEE FROM OUT OF
THE TRIED TO THE TRIBE. AND I
DIDN'T HEAR IT EXACTLY. WAS IN
YOUR REMARKS YEAH SO BOTH TRIBES
WILL BE PAYING. THEIR PRO RATA
SHARE TO THE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND WHICH IS USED
TO COVER STATE REGULATORY COSTS.
IN ADDITION SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA
WILL BE PAYING TO PAYING INTO
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND.
WHEN IT'S OPERATING OVER ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED GAMING
DEVICES. AND THAT MONEY IS USE
THAT FOR DISTRIBUTIONS TO
LIMITED AND NON GAMING TRIBES
FOR ONE POINT ONE MILLION
ANNUALLY AND IT CAN ALSO BE MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR COMING FOR OTHER ANY
OTHER MEMBER COMMENTS. MISTER
BILL. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
SUCCESSFUL NEGOTIATION THE
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNMENT YOU
HEARD ME SAID EARLIER IS A- HUGE
PART OF THIS IN UNDERSTANDING
THE SUCCESS OF ANY NEGOTIATION.
WITH TRAVEL AGREEMENT SO I WANT
TO CONGRATULATE YOU GUYS RIGHT
UP FRONT AND LET YOU KNOW THAT
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND
MOVING FORWARD. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE YEARS TO COME. ONLY A COUPLE
NUMBERS WORK AND I WANT TO TRY
TO BE AS RESPECTFUL TO EVERYBODY
AS POSSIBLE- IF THERE WAS ANY
COMMENTS. THAT YOU LIKE TO MAKE. THANK YOU. I DON'T SEE ANY
BILL OR WILL CONTINUE I WANT TO
THANK. OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND BOTH CHAIRMAN FOR ON.
EXTREMELY HARD AT THIS- FORGET
AHEAD OF MYSELF WE GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT PHONE ON THE TELEPHONE.
N. F. THE ITEM I READ THEM- YOU
KNOW GO TO THE TO THE LINES- MR
OR MADAM OPERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ON THE PHONES TO
COMMENT THIS POST ONE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE'S KEYPAD AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
ONLINE TWO SIXTY TWO WAS GOING
TO. ONE TWO SIX TO TWO MONTHS
EARLIER ONE MOMENT AND COME BACK
. OKAY LINE TO SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WILL INFLUENCE. HI
THIS IS DAVID QUINTANAR ON
BEHALF OF THE HAVE BEEN BEEN
FULL PROMO OF UPPER LAKE AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UNABLE TO
GET THROUGH EARLIER BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE OUR MONTHS ARE
STRONG IT SUPPORT TO OUR HOME-
NEIGHBORS THE MIDDLETOWN ON
THERE WHEN YOU COME BACK THINK.
NUMBER STRUCTURE THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTERS IN Q. IF
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CORE HERE TO COMMENT. CNN AND
ALL THE KEEP MY COMMENTS BEFORE
THE SAID THAT WERE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAVE WORKED EXTREMELY
HARD ON THIS ADDRESS ALL THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES- THAT WERE
FOUND BEFORE US. INTO BOTH
GERMANS- WHO WORKED EXTREMELY
HARD. IN IN GOVERNMENT THE
GOVERNMENT- NEGOTIATIONS OF
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND-
WE LOOK FOR SUPPORT AVAILABLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU M. FOR
HEARING AND THAT WILL COME OUR
ON THERE'S AN ANY OTHER COMMENTS
TO BE MADE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND CONGRATULATIONS.